[Music]
Susanna's in Columbus Ohio hey Suzanne
how are you hi I'm good thank you so
much for taking my call
sure what's up well I'm a noona listener
and I just finished the Total Money
Makeover today and yesterday we
completed baby step one but about eight
months ago we did some really stupid
things when we bought a house that were
in now the biggest of which was buying
it before I got my paycheck my first
paycheck from a new job that I just
started and when we got to Maytag we
discovered that my pay was about 40%
less than what we had figured it was
going to be due to mandatory retirement
that was taken out taxes were a lot
higher and our insurances were higher
than we thought they were going to be so
fast forward to today last week we put
the house on the market because we just
decided that we can't afford it we've
been trying to increase our income by
selling some stuff and I'm looking for a
part-time job but my question is until
our income increases do we default on
our other payments or to keep paying the
mortgage or do we allow the house to go
into foreclosure while we're still
trying to continue with the baby steps
what other debt do you have other than
your home we have 20,000 on a camper
which we're trying to sell we have 3,000
on a credit card and 2,000 and medical
okay and what does your husband make a
year can you make it makes about 38 and
I make about 22 okay there's that
take-home pay yes sir okay she have a
$60,000 income how much is your house
payment
19:25 okay are you doing your written
every dollar budget yet yes I just
started I just got that all entered last
week okay she been doing the whole week
okay yeah well yeah the campers up for
sale the house is up for sale we're
changing as many directions
as we can hear a garage sale is an order
Craigslist Craigslist stuff is for sale
all right all that kind of stuff is
going on both of you are looking for
part-time jobs that's that that's a good
thing
to get this to balance I think though
how much is the payment on the camper
it's 220 okay I was making payments of
250 to try to pay it down faster but
then you know we stopped doing that to
start doing the baby stuff yeah I think
you can make all these payments you're
gonna have no life but I think you can
make these payments
okay let's prioritize though to help you
with that but I I mean you got 2300 and
you got 5,000 our take-home pay on those
two payments is 2300 and that leaves you
1,700 to buy food and lights you know
you ought to be making this I don't
think you're in default but we have four
kids yeah but we're not gonna be paying
for piano lessons in our house is under
foreclosure okay so you know if you
choose them between house foreclosure
and that the kids get to you know we're
gonna everyone's limiting lifestyle
right now because we're in a crisis mode
now I'm gonna say I'm not saying don't
feed them but a short short of that you
can make this you just got to tighten
down so anyway here's your priorities
the first thing you buy is food
groceries not eating out you don't need
to sit out you don't need to see the
inside of a restaurant less your work in
there then the second thing you do
should pay lights and water okay the
third thing you do is you pay a house
payment okay
the fourth thing you do you don't have
any car payments you keep gas you keep
gas in the car so yeah what I just did
dent I and what I just did was the what
we call the four walls but it's old its
old 7th grade civics lesson the
necessities of life or food shelter
clothing transportation and utilities we
do those first that keeps the four walls
of your house standing you have a place
to live
it's heated the kids are eating
everybody's eating we're driving the
cars and going to work and that's really
that that's where we start is getting
these real basic necessities of life
taking care of you've got enough to
cover all of that that wasn't the camper
and that wasn't the MasterCard okay with
a credit card okay they're there the
last thing on the list is the camper
okay actually I pay the camper for paid
the credit card but the last two things
on the list are the the the camper and
then the credit card because the credit
card can't do anything
short-term except except damage your
credit a short-term the camper could
repo you if you just quit paying it all
together but you got it up for sale so
we're gonna get rid of that that's gonna
be helpful so I think you're going to
get through this but what you've got to
do is just prioritize from most
important thing to least important thing
the least important thing I heard in
this list so far is the credit card next
to that's the camper mm-hmm
the most important thing is your family
being taken care of food shelter
clothing transportation and utilities
see what the medical bills come in on
that you didn't mention you had medical
bills yeah mm and medical okay then they
would be down there by the credit card
because there's nothing there's nothing
they can do secured debts come before
unsecured debts and both are at the
bottom once we get past necessities okay
because secured debts they can take
stuff unsecured debts they just bother
you right eventually they'll sue you and
eventually they'll garnish you but
you're going to get to this long before
that happens because the house is going
to smell the camper is gonna sell you're
gonna be in a better place I mean this
is a matter of months it's not a matter
of years okay so you survive three
months doing this you're gonna be you
know everything's gonna turn the house
is gonna sell camper is gonna sell
you're gonna be the other side of this
you're gonna be going man we almost
screwed that up right but we got out of
it by the skin of our teeth right that's
what you're going to be saying thank god
you're turning the corner here but
here's the thing if you eat and have
lights and water and have a place to
live and you have transportation
emotionally the rest of it is just a
Monopoly game in your behind but when
you get inside your house inside those
four
and you start having the lights turned
off or getting foreclosed on in your
homeless or that kind of stuff now
emotionally your relationship
everything's been invaded then and your
stress level goes through the roof but
if you separate necessities from the
rest of it's just a game I'm losing
right now I can lose a game but I don't
lose my house all right that makes sense
yeah yeah that lowers your stress level
it's not going to go away until you get
rid of the house in the camper but it
lowers your stress level and if these
collectors call just say you know you're
you're too far down the list I can't get
to you right now mm-hmm I'd like to but
I can't get to you you know you're on
the list and the more you call the
further on the list you drop let's just
have some fun with it right I'm we're
not setting out to destroy your credit
we're not setting out to not pay bills
that wasn't your plan it's not my plan
but I'm gonna take care of your family
first because that's the best way for
your bills to actually get paid later is
if you get this out of order you're
gonna get all stressed out and it's
going to mess up your marriage and
you're gonna end up in bankruptcy court
and divorce court and all those stuff we
don't want any of that stuff going on no
yeah we're just gonna lock arms here and
fight our way through this a little bit
of stupidity and it'll be in your
rear-view mirror within a year oh I know
it will they put the house on the market
competitively put the camper on the
market competitively get themselves
priced competitively good question thank
you for joining us
sometimes when you're scared and I've
been scared you're been scared skier
they're been scared I've been scared man
I've been terrified sometimes when
you're doing that it's hard to think
clearly one good rule of thumb when
you're facing something like that where
the fear is coming at you is just stop
and break the problem down into
bite-size pieces and go okay what can I
do what what variables can I control
okay our family can eat that's good so
we're not hungry
one less thing to worry about lights and
water are on mmm okay we're bathing
and we are drinking water and we have
electricity so we have heating and
cooling one less thing to worry about
we're gonna pay the rent of the mortgage
mmm now I have a place to live and do
all that we're gonna put gas in the car
so we can go to work
yep or pay that car payment if you got
one right now and you start working your
way down these necessities first and you
really start understanding the rest of
this stuff is just a really ugly game
and you work your way through it and
that's all we did there you can do this
too if you need help you call here we're
here to help people it's a pretty simple
thing this is the Dave Ramsey show